hey what's up youtube it is marcus
brownlee here from mkbhd and welcome to
tech channel of the week number seven
now the tech channel of the week has
been a relatively new series it's been
going well uh pretty successful other
people have picked up this uh video
series themselves and gone with it and i
like that's pretty cool
uh but i just wanna let you guys know
this is the original tech channel of the
week this is number seven and this
channel is tectonic um and this channel
uh when i first came across it not that
long ago actually uh he had a few dozen
subscribers and he had a lot of videos
and most of them were actually on [ __ ]
and i'm just gonna give you um just
gonna give you a general tour around his
channel right here since i think you
guys would be interested in his youtube
channel
excuse me so starting on the left hand
side uh we can see obviously he has 310
subscribers i think we can get up to 500
uh and a few you can get him up to 500
guys he's got a great channel he's got a
lot of videos and you guys like what he
does here he has 6225
channel views
right now he does have a large selection
of videos and tutorials if we scroll
down here we see he has 64 videos and if
we go ahead and click on and watch his
most recent videos he does have a lot of
videos more recently on a number of
different topics but i'm going to go to
the most viewed section
because a lot of these are on [ __ ] and
when he first started doing tutorials
which is when i was an earlier an early
subscriber he did a number of videos
on how to make a youtube channel
background which i was going to do that
tutorial but then i watched his and i
figured i would refer all my subscribers
to that video when they asked
how to change a person's face in [ __ ]
how to get a windows dock in vista
change a skin color in [ __ ] make a
youtube banner and [ __ ] all these
different tutorials uh in [ __ ] that are
actually really quite cool making your
own channel icon and [ __ ] all these
different things
and i think that's really cool he knows
how to do quite a bit using this this
particular piece of freeware
so i'll go back to his channel page real
quick his featured video as he's been
expanding into different types of
software has been an introduction to
downloading torrents so if any of you
guys have any question about torrance
you can obviously watch this video and
get a good sense of what torrents are
like i recently watched it and it's a
very good video i will scroll down here
just a little bit uh he does have um he
keeps his announcements down here in his
recent activity box so he has a new
channel design and also a new logo he
lets you guys know when he has a new
video ready and when he's uh going to be
uploading a video so that's very very
nice
um also we're gonna go back here to uh
recent videos and you can also see uh
he's done a number of videos on um more
of the complicated things for example
how to make your own brush for [ __ ] uh
and that's that's more of an advanced
tutorial i know you guys uh have been
you know asking for different types of
software this is a pretty pretty nice uh
channel for uh photo editing
with this particular piece of freeware
so again if you want to check out this
channel the link will be in the
description
youtube.com
tectonic and that'll be
t-e-c-h-t-o-n-i-c-c
you can contact him
and i hope we can get him to his 500
plus subscriber goal down there on the
left-hand side
anyway this has been marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd if you do like [ __ ] and
if you do like technology uh you should
check out tech techtonic's channel which
will be in the description and that is
basically it thanks for watching guys
peace